Speaker 1: Our voicemail number is 219 to David
P and you can call that voicemail number any
time. Here is a viewer who unfortunately,
like many of my viewers and listeners,
is really confused. About my view of
the Democratic Party. Take a listen.
Speaker 5: I just want to know why
you think the Democrats are so in
great need. To be honest, I don't care
if you do or not. They are just message.
Explain to me how the Democrats
are so great at higher gas prices.
Unemployment at an all time high.
I can name enough, but all the
borders. Come on, man. Wake up. Yeah.
Speaker 1: So, listen, first of all,
almost nothing this guy said is true.
Open borders. Border policy is almost
completely unchanged from Trump to Biden. Almost
completely unchanged. Record high unemployment.
We have record low unemployment. Record low
unemployment, mid-thirties. We are essentially
at full employment, high gas prices. Gas prices
are down dramatically. And really, they have very
little to do with the president of the United
States. I didn't blame Trump when gas prices
went up and I didn't praise Trump when gas prices
went down. I didn't blame Biden when gas prices
went up. And I didn't praise Biden when gas prices
went down. It really doesn't have much to do with
the president at all. But maybe the most important
confusion that this caller has is I don't say the
Democratic Party is so great, not even a Democrat.
Again, my view is that the Democratic Party is an
organization whose main goal is to preserve its
own existence, preserve its own existence. I don't
care about the party at all. To the extent that
in any particular race, the better candidate is
a Democrat, I'll vote for the Democrat. That's as
far as my allegiance goes to any political party.
And so this is not a show where I say vote blue
no matter who or the Democratic Party is great,
or whatever the case may be. This is a show
where I say, I don't care about political
party. I'm not a member of any political party.
I evaluate candidates for their policy and for
their platforms, and I decide who closely or more
closely aligns with me. Sometimes it really is
an option of bad and less bad, and I choose the
less bad option. I think most reasonable people
would. And sometimes there are actual Democratic
candidates that I like and I sort of willingly and
gladly vote for as well. But please criticize me
for things I actually say, not things you imagine
I said. We have a great bonus show for you today.
We are going to talk about this wacky Dr. Oz story
where experiments, research he was involved in
reportedly led to the deaths of more than 300
dogs. The story is a little more complicated
than the headlines make it out to be, which
is why I'm glad to have the opportunity on the
bonus show to discuss it. California Democratic
Governor Gavin Newsom, who is a potential
2024 presidential contender, has signed a bill
decriminalizing most jaywalking in California.
Who cares, right? Jaywalking is actually a tool
that is used to criminalize and to create a
pretext for interactions between police and
citizens and residents. And it's actually a really
important bill. We're going to talk about why. And
The Onion, the satirical publication, defends its
right to parody in a very real Supreme Court brief
relating to a satirist. This is also a year when
these folks on the right talk about free speech.
They really are talking about free speech
of a certain type for certain people.
They claim it's about all free speech, but it's
really not. This is a really interesting case,
actually, about free speech. All of those stories
and more coming up today on the bonus show.
Speaker 4: Thank your lucky stars
every day. You're not David Pakman.
Speaker 1: Well, I have the pleasure of
hosting the bonus show every single day.
You can sign up at join Pacman dot com, become
a member and we will see you on the bonus show
in just a moment. Otherwise, we'll be
back tomorrow with a brand new program.